hachimachi that middle class famous tour
is in full swing gipperino you ain't
lying fatty it's a live comedy show we
play a little ayg with the crowd great
way to introduce people to the show
bring the squad come out and see us
we're coming baby yeah gang these
tickets are selling quickly uh so make
sure you get your tickets we're coming
in we're going to be red bank new jersey
then we're going to seattle portland all
in august then in september we're going
kansas city springfield st louis then
we're going down to nashville hitting
indy coming home to philly baby the
chicken's got to come home to roost yeah
then we're hitting providence rhode
island up there to bean town get those
tickets let's go welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage uh-huh little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the girl to be classy
yeah they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at antoni's basement she just got
back from a nice three-day weekend okay
at central booking wow i told her you
don't start [ __ ] in the parking lot of a
phillies game on a weekend cause the
judge don't come till monday yeah my
co-host is coming at you unamused this
week right next to me we're going to
fire these writers i'm telling you right
now he is the prince of park avenue but
always the king of the boardwalk baby
give it up for kj kevin james ryan hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are schroeder
and then obviously the greatest website
of all time www.patreon.com
are you garbage check it the [ __ ] out
that money party over there how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he works the ones and twos
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen everybody hey what's up dude
there he is oh we got a hot one today
baby star power in this [ __ ] as
my aunt would say she brought the
weather with her
a long hair ain't lying folks not the
usual bums and bozos you see walking in
here we got a little star
oil joint here we couldn't be more
excited to have our incredibly and i
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time she is a
legendary stand-up comedian actor writer
director producer and podcaster true of
course she is the host of the amazing
podcast good for you you might have seen
her in but not limited to sit back put
on a cup of coffee this is going to take
a couple of minutes
what are you reading from me
is that your suicide note
[Laughter]
it's all just letters taped together
from cosmo
all right gang you've seen her and what
about brian the 710 split
tell me you'll love me okay this is
grizzly
what are you talking about we're
celebrating these are earned credits
here maid of honor house the jim
gaffigan show they're ridiculous six
undateable workaholics marin
unforgettable no these aren't adjectives
adam ruins everything how it ends tacoma
fd studio 666 good morning entertainment
tonight kelly clarkson james corden 10
episodes of wendy williams which she
co-hosted jimmy kimmel live six episodes
of that also hosted that 10 episodes of
kelly and ryan guess what co-hosted that
you've seen her on the view self-help
list the tonight show lights out with
david spade conan ellen the today show
the joe rogan experience match game
tiger belly seth myers
[Laughter]
she's been on every goddamn show out
there folks
pizzagate what the [ __ ]
craig ferguson letterman chelsea lately
60 episodes of that no big [ __ ] deal
you got jay leno you got the pete holm
show kill tony carson daley your mom's
house but listen here's the real [ __ ]
turkey right here now you have the the
amazing film the female brain which she
wrote directed and started then you have
her own sitcom 38 episodes by the way it
also says andrew schultz in it and he's
trying to buy it back from me
really annoying i'm like
johnson we love you
that's a good piece of business right
there
but hang on
all right we got 38 episodes of whitney
which she co-created co-wrote and
starred in then you got this little
program called two broke girls
38 episodes we do have tits
she created and starred in and produced
that she also produced and wrote on the
roseanne revival then you got the comedy
specials you have money shot you have i
love you i'm your girlfriend
can i touch it and of course the brand
new special out on netflix right now
called jokes ladies and gentlemen she is
one of the funniest one of the hardest
working one of the most successful
comedians coming around the [ __ ]
block and we got her down here at
toadies do me a favor give it up for the
one the only whitney cummings yeah look
at that look at that and let me be clear
i asked to be honest
you were so far out of the world i
wouldn't even know how to get to you
like i might have used star maps last
time i was in hollywood
a little
uh no but i literally asked for i was
doing birth show and i was like i want
to do that joe and he hooked me up
thanks for having me of course shut up
we knew that would come all that might
be we've had a lot of you know a lot of
big timers in here that might be the
most correct yeah i mean that's what 138
episodes of two broke girls we're
talking about early 2000's network
sitcom you can't walk into a hotel room
and that's right okay
uh it was in color to be fair
uh let me just say
1944. that's what i'm saying bozo you
get a show on network now we're talking
when it was the real deal it's called
two gals at the time
uh no yes i guess it was
that's [ __ ] that is insane also i
love the pandering of the phillies saint
patty's day okay that's top-notch
dirtbag you could play aunt hoodie in a
movie
the early years the uh you're the
prequel to the karen antony okay so let
me just tell you really i am wearing a
vintage philly shirt that's not vintage
what do you mean vintage touch it touch
it touch it it has leprosy touch it
polio so there is a uh store in
nashville called starstruck vintage and
whenever i perform in nashville i go
there and i get gifts for people okay i
give them on you know my podcast because
i can't promise them the numbers you
guys can promise people so um i have to
give them gifts to lure them in i have
200 bucks on my checking account
i am proper poor you know what you
should do after this sue me
now we're talking slip and fall what do
you want to do do you know rob mcelhenny
in philadelphia so he comes on the show
you know yeah proper do we know him yeah
we were at his beach house i don't
[ __ ] know him every also every dirt
bag in philly has like a six degrees
connection to rock like i got a cousin
who's like i once punched him in the
cafeteria i'm like all right all right i
must have known him that well did you
see how gingerly i said his last name
um but so i got this for him and then i
never was able to like give it to him
and i was like oh my god i'm going to
honor your garbage they're philly and
then i made this stupid dumb horror
mistake of being like everyone from one
place low like is this good or bad yeah
that's a hunt that's 100 of a home run
yeah that's i mean is this a good shirt
that shirt was probably that was a bar
crawl that was uh maybe given out at the
at a phillies game they were big on
saint patty's day can you see what yeah
i mean this is like years have you ever
looked at a tag the year's not on it's
not it's
but you will probably see like this
company's not in business anymore
because of child labor it's definitely
it's yeah it's one of the gildans or
whatever it is yeah it's probably from
the 80s
it's aged yeah it's all yeah it's not
don't look at my face when you say that
to the shirt
i think it's a 55.
so i was like you know what what am i
going to do with this i'm fantastic i'm
just going to wear it and pander we love
it we love it give us which is a [ __ ]
garbage move i know
also you rolled up in a pretty nice car
by the way pretty fake driver and all
got out open the door
i've been in premium ubers they don't
get out they barely slow down for money
what is that and you tagged the car
company in the store yes i did what is
that uh it me uh look i am hemorrhaging
money
and the closing show's perfect for you
do you want to get in a nascar because
that's what we're about to do i just
want a business class trip to europe by
the way i am out of money
but no i definitely am do the pay to
post thing you know like or what's it
called sorry paid partnership so it's
like yes audi said if you you know when
you're doing press in new york uh we can
give you a ride but like tag us damn
that's [ __ ] so they just you just get
a car yeah they'll just drive around but
i have to be corny and be like hey guys
here i am and i have to lose my friends
to me i've lost yeah i judged you
immediately yeah everybody hates me is
he outside waiting for you
is he your guy for the whole time you're
here for just for like a couple rides
tonight yeah before i go to the seller
he'll drop me off
two blocks away it's like having your
dad it's like can you join me off like
two blocks away so none of the comedians
see me get out what are you talking
about
you pull up right in the front tell
those [ __ ] bozos to kick rocks tell
them to watch it
here's the thing about new york i never
really got it down i've spent a ton of
time here but i'm not like great at you
i don't have a great sense of direction
and walking around new york is
always embarrassing because um i'll do
the uh maps that'll be like okay left
here and then i'll be like at the corner
you gotta look up and look down
you might as well have a sign there's
like eight people around me just like oh
like it's so it's like that girl
yeah like it's just embarrassing i look
like the make-a-wish kid trying to get
to the where's the m store
there are fuddruckers near here let's
get into the origin story of whitney
cummings yeah you've got two where are
you from bbc so born in washington dc
okay like proper uh
wasn't at the white house georgetown
okay so georgetown i know which sounds
fancy but i was in an apartment i don't
want to brag so
i have a couple little weird things
about my childhood in terms of like you
know the kid that lived in an apartment
that was one sure and then there were
kids that lived with their aunts
or an aunt and uncle i would sweet life
of zack and cody we were talking about
cause listen on paper when i looked you
up when i looked it up yeah
it looks pretty classy yeah okay mm-hmm
it looks pretty nice yes that's what i
hear
what everyone says i've also seen it on
paper yeah but i lived it and it's
stunned but fill us in what's up so i
did live um i was born in washington dc
okay hospital but grew up in georgetown
basically a block south of the street
where in a few good men to me more and
tom cruise are in the rain yelling at
each other okay that's dent place
uh so like near there um but i lived in
like apartments right across from a
place called dumbarton oaks which is
kind of famous can you shoot your mic up
a little bit sorry oh i thought you were
going to say something to me
sorry this is the first time your mic's
not on by the way
this is the first time amanda's ever
wanted me to be louder so i'm just
trying to turn it up just yeah um and uh
and so uh i grew up in washington dc but
spent my summers in a place called
roanoke virginia okay i know the name
you know roanoke but not roanoke island
there was i think that's what i know as
like the vacation spot well there was
one that disappeared
remember roanoke islands
all cities are constructs i don't know
if you know this but there's a place
called roanoke island right when um
whatever the british first colonized and
then it disappeared maybe yeah i know i
know the name roanoke yeah so there's
roanoke virginia so my aunts lived there
so because of custody stuff and you know
family stuff i lived there half the time
and then as i got older i went actually
to high school in roanoke virginia when
i was like 10 11
they're still all with the ants yes
living with two on two ants who are you
with in the apartment is that the main
question do you say aunt or aunt
i mean i'm a female that should be one
it's anne right i say patty yeah yeah
daddy and carol yeah
so then i was living full-time in
roanoke virginia and then i would uh
spend my summers in west virginia played
called harpers ferry west virginia where
my dad managed a hotel called hilltop
house hotel so i was kind of equally and
all did you stay at the hotel yeah all
the time and i'm actually i'm actually
like shit's creek i'm working with some
people right now to renovate it actually
yeah that's all wow
well it's also west virginia it's you
know coming from there i spent so much
time you know being ridiculed and being
made fun of that i would sort of pretend
more like i'm from dc i have no like you
really want to distance yourself and
then i did an appearance on the james
corden show and um i made jokes about
being from there and i got all this wild
uh
backlash or whatever it is the first
time i actually really ever felt bad
because i hadn't been back as an adult
and i went back and sure enough there's
no clean water and it's just disgusting
the way that area is treated so i was
like what can i do you know what they
need five-star hotel
they need plush robes
you know they need a massage
but no it would help bring union jobs to
the area and clean water and there you
go look it's like the capital of
industry we'll see we'll see but i'm not
financing i'm just we're trying to make
a show about it and help uh rehabilitate
appalachia that's [ __ ] [ __ ] sweet
look at that but in the apartment in
georgetown it was your parents and then
they split up they split up yeah but i
was about five so they um we're only
like two blocks from each other when
they first split up okay that my family
did my mom and dad at a very similar
they were way too close it's like you
could have just stayed in the house
what are we doing when you get older do
you ever feel like when your parents got
divorced they might still have been in
love
i think it was a pretty solid no my
parents stayed together and i'm pretty
sure they hate each other but i mean in
a sick way like amber and johnny like i
was watching that trial and i was like
will they won't it like this feels like
i just want to see each other of course
yeah this was so one nested it's one of
those things of like trying to get the
attention and trying to get the event
and then it just escalated like i feel
like i'm like you guys get divorced and
you move two blocks from it like there's
something yeah you still want to bump
into each other at the [ __ ]
supermarket just as you become an adult
and you realize that a lot of people you
break up but you still kind of are
obsessed with the person i feel like i
know that's their favorite restaurant
maybe i'll walk by i'm just gonna yeah
i'll get drunk and punch a bouncer
i had a girl break up with me one time
and i knew she was the opposite that she
definitely never wanted to see me again
because she put all my stuff in a trash
bag and had it waiting at the door but
he didn't have that much stuff
apparently she folded everything very
neatly and put it in the trash bag and
that's how i knew this woman never wants
to see me again
we won't be bumping into each other at
the grocery store walk me through that
so she so she wanted it to look nice
yeah she wanted to make sure that it was
definite so that you couldn't go it
wasn't but it did this it wasn't like an
activity
it wasn't like you did yeah
and serial killer asked like we are done
let me put a bow on this and move it out
yeah that's not a passion that's that's
rational that's you're you're working
with logic at that point someone with
ocd i do think there's
another version of this story but you
just hate it
i'll probably second that's what it was
all right uh by the way
naming where a movie was filmed to mark
the gfa geographical location pretty
garbage i like you know what
i was trying to make
yeah i was trying to make you like me
that's like
fame like you know oh yeah
i don't know why i was like there's a
bunch of guys they probably like that
movie i do like the movie like they'll
know that i was near that jack they'll
think i'm cool even as a kid there's a
movie there's a movie theater where they
shot the blob the original blob near
where i live and every time we drive by
they're pretty shot like their stars are
still hanging out out front dude my only
james cagney is still posting up there
mom they shot signs in my hometown and
claimed we hung out on the street
looking for mel gibson for five months
you know where he was bar noir
so i would he was at bar noir so i went
to college in philadelphia when they
were shooting that and he was at that
place barnard pretty much every night
really he likes a cocktail from yeah
that's right you did go to school in
philadelphia all right this is making
sense you went too if i might
pretty hoity toity as they would call it
in in philadelphia university of penn
state
you can tell altoona campus you can tell
if some someone from penn is either cool
or not based on the way they react when
someone goes oh you want penn state
if they're like oh
i'll just i'm like sure yes university
of pennsylvania but ivy league i've
heard of it but
what do you do with the fact that i took
uh extra classes and summer courses at
temple
i'm an owl myself okay who let's go by
the way you gotta get weed what are you
gonna do anyway not just the center city
campus
1916 the main campus wow this is cry
friday oh all right went to college and
did some classes with uh more than one
cosby oh yeah you went to the university
of pennsylvania come on yes don't
sugarcoat it
went to temple back when there was a
statue of bill cosby like out front i
mean he was he was big time when i was
he was still big time when i was there
and jello pudding man you couldn't touch
him oh my god those jigglers that's
right they were awesome yeah that was
bad back then too that oh i was it
rehabilitated when i like right before i
got there
yeah and i i remember trying to go to
classes down there and you would take
the train and there were times you just
couldn't get there because there would
be like shootings and stuff and you just
you know it was wild it's a very hot
yeah but hmm
obviously you did good in school in high
school
good grades yes i did i was in her i was
a dork in high school i was i worked
really hard what was the essay i mean
you work very hard in comedy too so it
makes sense thank you uh yes i do um
that's my favorite thing and that i'm
not taking that personally but i do love
uh when i come off stage and people are
like you really
work hard
it's really up there trying look at you
you're such a good writer yeah you can't
kick an ass
no i'm just like for some reason like i
still have this like like
thing because there's the thing of like
you don't want to try you just go and do
it
like just like
instead of just being like oh you're
funny people like you she really works
really hard and you're like but um but i
also think that for the longest time in
the beginning that was like really
unattractive and not cool like people
really held it against me i think that's
super [ __ ] cool well i was like i'm
poor like i need to make money like i
can't this is a hobby for me like i have
to yeah it's a job at the end of the day
um but sorry what was the question sats
oh god um
uh
i got it's got to be 14 15 something
it's
14 but i i i something it was 14
something but i had to redo the english
because of something and then the main
ones you know how like if you get one
bubble off they're all off
now yeah you know yeah i got it
so i don't know what you're talking
about
welcome to the show you want to know
what's crazy about that [ __ ] is that
it's they're they're not doing it
anymore look at this a 14 something and
an 870 sitting in the same [ __ ] room
but no but i also did a thing my
underwear on backwards the sats has
nothing to do with intelligence in fact
i think the better you do on it probably
the the less creative and interesting
you are i had to go take those um
classes where they taught you how to
take the sats
i took those classes i went after school
and then before school like the prep
course 6 38 because i had no id i'm so
dyslexic like i couldn't understand the
um what is it when it's like a a
slice a slice of bread is to loaf
as what's that called not a symbol an
analogy an analogy i could not [ __ ]
do those and i had started jeans i could
i had to have all these little cheeks i
had a piece of paper i think they gave
me extra time it was a whole thing yeah
because i i couldn't understand how to
do those i meant to slice a bread thing
is that correct slice of bread
slice of bread is to loaf i made up the
second half about the jeans that sounded
real smart wait that's like the main
crumb is to bread
as no rock is to boulder
yes okay
yes
i would have got that one wrong like
i would have said we got stuck up on the
bread
i would have been getting more butter
over here before i would have been
looking for peanut butter and jelly in
one of the answers kev let's talk about
that liquid iv baby love that stuff
summer months are here's to dog days
this summer we're coming into august you
want to stay hydrated you want to stay
healthy and let me tell you something
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water will hydrate you better and faster
than regular water i use it at the gym
it powers me through my workouts and i
feel fantastic kippy what do you got
let's get to the turkey i use it after a
hard night of drinking and it gets me
back to life baby bacon making cheese
will turn your day around you ain't
lying it's better than other sports
drinks other drinks other hangover
recipes liquid iv has you because it
contains five essential vitamins b3 b5
b6 b12 and vitamin c all the bees
contains three times the electrolysis
traditional sports drinks that aren't
going to be named here yeah that's right
uh it's music rock exposure with premium
ingredients and free from gluten dairy
and soy there you go so listen if you
want to feel great or if you're in a
hole and you're trying to feel better
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquid iv.com and use code garbage
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you shop for better hydration
today using promo code garbage at
liquidity.com
yeah okay let's talk about movement
movement come on don't play stupid with
me you wanna get laid to get a movement
watch that's right
a couple of those blue blocker
sunglasses whatever they got over there
tell you what they started out a tiny
apartment a couple of college dropouts
just two guys with their backs against
the wall and a dream and they turned the
watch business up on their heads
how do they do it over there and you're
probably sitting there they probably
only shipped to a couple of states
160 countries across the globe
shipping to mars get on vacation you're
on vacation get a new [ __ ] movement
watch yeah come back heavy yeah uh they
were nice enough to send us a couple of
those blue blocker glasses my broad
wears them when she's working on a
computer over there doing excel
spreadsheets helps the eyes helps with
the sleeve i wear them when i'm watching
my movies
yeah i wear my watch i have it i'm not a
big watch guy but as you can see watch
my fan i wear it out on dates with the
bra she loves it yeah she's slipping off
the cg
uh movement watches has uh they have the
looking quality of a 400 the 500 watch
where that you're paying for at a
department store but at a cost at a cost
and fresh a fraction of the price
because they were built online with
their own process from start to finish
there's no middleman it cut them out of
them right to you that's right pass the
savings on we mentioned the blue light
glasses uh the the ever scroll blue
light filtering glasses those it's too
much screen time everybody get your
headaches gives you migraines you can't
sleep those bullets are gonna kill you
yeah so the blue light ever scroll uh
filtering glasses are a game changer if
you want to elevate your look with style
that doesn't break the bank then join
movement mvmt and get 15 off today with
free shipping free returns by going to
mvmt.com garbage one more time write it
down get your phone out type it in there
mvmt.com garbage do it yeah totally so
so they actually talked to someone who's
um uh my nieces uh has to do s.a.t soon
they're not doing them
yeah they're so not the way that it is
it's not like a reflection of
intelligence but you did well at
university of penn
um yeah i think would you major in uh
embarrassing communications and film
i mean yeah no it ended up perfect
people made fun of communications myself
included as a major but it for me i feel
like at least the school i went to was
the best preparation for being a
comedian because it was all criticism of
other things it was like criticism of
advertisements criticism of television
like how average study and medium
video games on violence it was all that
kind of stuff i assume you're one of the
most successful people to go through
their film program have you gone back to
do anything a lecture like uh you know a
whitney cummings hall or something um
coming talk
um uh i did speak at the annenberg
commencement like a couple years ago
there you go yeah i got in a lot of
trouble here's the thing
it's fancy if i did it but is it garbage
if i had to get got trouble because i
cursed a bunch it's [ __ ] uh i know i
got in trouble so i got asked to do it
which is impressive but then i got asked
to get off stage as quickly as possible
they're lighting you in the back show
those nerds what's up because i was
talking because there was this um this
teacher dr carolyn marvin who changed my
life she taught freedom of speech and uh
she used to oh first amendment she used
to burn the american flag on campus she
used to throw a liberal [ __ ]
toby
[Laughter]
and she taught um us the carlin uh the
words
yeah and i sort of said like you're such
a big part of why i got into comedy and
i said some of the words in a bunch of
yeah i know
and uh so a bunch of parents got mad at
me a ponytail and a turtleneck on yeah
i'm going full carl park in the driveway
all right okay okay okay all right um
nobody i assume lives in the apartment
anymore that you grew up on right no but
my mom had a stroke and we had to sell
it okay what was the name of that street
our street
our street you know what it was a half
do you know when apartments had
addresses that were a half like 60 40
and a half that's the first on a yg is
it jesus
60 40 and a half r street 60 30 60 30.
longitude latitude what are you talking
about that sounds like it's right off
sesame street that's so that's
coordinates for a bomb
he lives next to the count
you've never seen an apartment that's a
half no i don't think so a b
yeah oh that's a new york thing yeah
yeah yikes all right okay any pets
growing up yes there were when i was
very young we had two cats uh buttons
and tiger i think they were just
standard street cats that we fed when
you are an adult and you look back um
and then lots of pet shop [ __ ] they're
with the guinea pig
like yeah guinea pigs that's the worst
smell that oh at half apartments
where are our guinea pigs they're i just
saw them they're on that island no
they're local they're local to some
country i forget why no but remember all
of my friends had guinea pigs when i was
a kid oh yeah people realized it was
[ __ ] trash and stopped buying yeah
and then by the way ant farms uh [ __ ]
uh gerbils we had gerbils too all that
it was pregnant yeah and then they would
we'd put them in fish tanks because we
couldn't afford the crates so you wake
up in the morning they'd just be gone
yeah and then i just go get new ones
with my allowance every day and you'd
hear in the middle of the night you hear
like they were in the walls like they
were everywhere
yeah is that your answer how did you get
in the pen that was in dc that's a great
question
i did get a zoology scholarship
we also did lots of
fish lots of and that place must have
stung oh dude lots
case yeah
i think they did tell you what are you
talking about everybody knows not to put
two betta fish things okay i had a fish
fight fight club when i was a kid
that was kind of a thing at one point i
put goldfish in with them you know i'm
like you know what this better fish
throw a gerbil in there it just needs
companions just needs yeah some
affection you know some eye contact yeah
it just needs some goldfish and then so
there was a lot of that there was
definitely a fish tank but at my dad's
house in the basement that was like
never cleaned
just
unclear what was even in there
uh you know once you have a fish tank
you can't really undo it you have to
wait for everything to kind of die yeah
it's a lot of maintenance so there's one
fish left so you keep for eight years
yeah you know kind of thing so there was
a lot of that treasure chest bubbling
down at the bottom
and then in roanoke virginia where i
lived uh that was basically a farm so we
had you know 10 horses okay by the way
not like an equestrian jumping
these are horses that are just out in
the field
they just it wasn't like rich people
horses yeah exactly it was poor people
told when they when they broke their leg
you just shoot them in the head like
that type of situation and then my
hamsters know to keep in line
see what happened to big boy don't you
you don't want that to happen to you and
then one of my aunts um she took in so
many animals all the time she was just
like they had this giant heart but she
would have the biggest heart and
everyone knew that she would take on any
animal so they would um tie animals to
her tree when they would get sick or
they couldn't afford the medical care so
you would wake up and there would just
be like a bassin hound a golden like so
she had 15 16 dogs in cats okay she had
lawn furniture in the house because
there was like no point of
yeah blankets on everything
you know the house that is always
everything is covered in plastic and
blankets so you don't even know what the
furniture actually looks like
damn
and then um a couple cats and then my
aunt that i i had two aunts they lived
at the end of a gravel road next to each
other and then one had three the two
ants lived next to each other like
adjacent probably the property
lines were touching was this at one time
was this at one time all
and what side is that on your aunts your
mom's or your dad's so was that at one
time all their property like did all did
they come did they have like
generational wealth going back um
my dad were like the gray gardens kind
of i was gonna say i have big eating
little lady energy no my grandfather
worked in um coal and
they no uh he might have bought them the
land but they split it okay
horses and gotcha okay that's trashy
though all right living next to a
sibling is trashy yeah that's so funny
yeah that's like i don't need to see
what's out there everything is right
here on this driveway you know what i'm
it's the devil you know i know i hate
you yeah
i know i'm gonna hate my name i'm gonna
hate this [ __ ] forever i want someone i
can at least slap
the police what was the sports situation
growing up sure so um uh once i got into
hi i got very serious about basketball
when i was in high school okay very
serious about basketball and if you
played basketball at the places i went
to high school you also played
volleyball because that was kind of the
other thing going on in the off season
the different seasons guys
can you take your mic up a little bit
toby
are you in love with me like why do you
need to hear my voice
no one else wants this
have you read youtube comments ever
about okay we stopped that alone okay
okay well i'm trying to help you here
trust me um so you would you would do
like lacrosse and soccer or you would do
basketball and volleyball they were kind
of just like similar yeah yeah of course
and you're tall you know you got a lot
of jumping involved yeah so i i didn't
love volleyball but i was like obsessed
with basketball
or did you think about playing
basketball in college yes i played um i
played aau
which was like holy [ __ ]
that's like sort of like my whole life
and then i went to um europe and played
with like uh what wait what with those
weird [ __ ] foul lines and going in on
an angle kick rocks with that [ __ ] oh
dude nba or nothing oh it was a
nightmare you would go it was like a one
of those like pre-olympic league kind of
thing oh god damn but you go and then
all of a sudden it's two 20-minute halfs
like it's a completely different and
then all soccer you're like what though
yeah what do you have like and then all
of the point guards are like german and
they're 6'4 and you're like oh [ __ ] you
know so that was you know wild but a lot
of the girls that i played with in that
league and aau went on to uconn and
tennessee and the great you know really
good program right right and now they're
stuck in russia
what other schools did you get into do
you remember or would you apply to god i
did you know what i didn't get into penn
uh
normally i think that i applied i i did
any big things i had to call rick singer
uh i had to get laurie laughlin's uh
admissions guy yeah um
uh i make it look like she plays
volleyball do you like hamsters and all
right i did have to pose in a canoe in
front of a green screen
uh in a great documentary on netflix by
the way i haven't seen it yet it's
really it's done really well because
they have all of the
they have all of this guys like footage
and stuff it's it's one i want to talk
about i want to talk to the guy is it
true that someone like flew to texas to
take the sats for the kid there was a
there was a pro they would go in and a
guy would take it yeah yeah yeah
dude he was ace in it he was like a sat
prep guy and he was ace in it and he was
only making like a thousand dollars a
test well that's [ __ ] up yeah
but but was no one like oh you're
40 well no what they do is like they get
they get the extra time he's like the
wood shop
i think he was the proctor of the test
the guy was
so then he would just he would sit there
and the guy or the kid the boy or girl
would take the test they go okay great
throw that in the [ __ ] trash can and
then he would just yeah this is the
result oh wow because of my kids to
[ __ ] have that the coaches at usc
um they were getting they were the ones
getting paid right under the table yeah
only one guy got caught the the canoe
guy or the crew crew water polo
something like that yeah i mean water
sport loco polo i don't know catch the
they catch the badminton guy they don't
they don't touch the football program
you don't slap the hand that feeds you
the sports they don't need but
apparently i did also hear that people
were suing usc the people that got in
the quote right way i mean everything is
unfair i mean the whole thing's [ __ ]
unfair even when you don't have someone
taking tests for you but um because now
having usc on your resume doesn't really
mean it's a little watered down yeah
they're like we spent whatever i went to
temple university folks
still owe them [ __ ] you might
now be the biggest uh
now that kind of get a 2-5 out of that
place
there's got to be a kicker in the nfl or
something
you got to be kidding me yeah i want to
make the notable alum
do you still play basketball now can you
still ball okay so look i'm no tom
segura
you love me tommy man that one really
got me um
but she's going after the big guys i i
did
uh uh i do have like a little like half
court in my yard okay i you know i broke
my shoulder
six years ago
and trying to dunk uh yeah trying to die
um masturbating um checking my likes on
instagram no i was dating a guy who was
very into snowboarding and i wanted to
him to think we were soul mates or
something stupid so i got i i
and shattered my shoulder yeah
they come get you on the hill cool oh
it's the whole thing like the saint
bernard and all that [ __ ]
it's not the iditarod don't they use
that i thought they sent a dog or
something to get you you went
snowboarding with a donner party right
yeah that what are you nuts it's a big
barrel of cocoa or the oregon trail
right
no they use snowmobiles you bozo that's
pretty sweet she's such a funny thought
um yeah so it was never been skiing by
the way that's his i don't think i know
what a saint bernard is either yeah it
was in montana a place called um
uh yellowstone club gorgeous and
amazing you cool rich person you do i
would this is the one non-broke i've
ever dated i believe that snowboarder
was a looker a mistake an older guy his
kid was in a snowboarding like they were
just very into it i never skied growing
up i think you have to have money to ski
to know how to do to do it right
otherwise you're out there in jeans and
you look like a [ __ ] ass no you're
doing the pizza pizza
i couldn't ski if you if you don't learn
early and it's just it's three grand
just to
[ __ ] and you can't just show up on a
[ __ ] ski a ski mountain in montana
yeah well i mean it's also like we got
it you have health insurance like cool
like
i just never skied never did any snow
sports and um i did uh a little training
session with the snowboard guy and i i
got it pretty quick like yeah but then
when you get down there and you're on
the broken collarbone tell you what
[ __ ] gets you dude is you get up
there and you're kind of getting it and
all these little [ __ ] with gopros
that are shooting their own reality show
or they're trying to get their tick
tocks they're like zooming in and so it
like really stresses you out because you
have these like people that are you know
trying to get youtube video watch me
hurt whitney cummings
so what'd you hit how'd you break the
shoulder uh so i fell forward
and broke my shoulder
couldn't get up went to the doctor just
on the snow on the snow it's like flat
on a on like a black diamond like down
and i go to the doctor and the doctor
was like this makes no sense you broke
your shoulder when you felt most people
that come in with this injury have their
noses broken they have concussions can't
hurt the moneymaker though you know what
i mean and then yeah when they're like
this doesn't make any sense how this
happened and uh i was like oh well you
know i
i feel like maybe i just i don't know i
didn't hit my head and they're like oh
well you have fake tits right i was like
yeah they're like oh well you probably
bounced off those so that's gonna let
your head get there it was a doctor from
the 50s
was he smoking a cig at this point
i got huge jugs lady are you guys
telling me that were you cooking when
this happened doll face what are you
doing out of the kitchen
jesus christ that's wild i was like are
you guys telling me my fake tits like
saved my life there you go it's very
rare that you would hit the snow and not
so maybe i i bounced off them how'd they
get you off the off the mountain oh so
embarrassing um they because i couldn't
get hurt because when you break your
shoulder you can't it's like it didn't
hurt but i just couldn't push
you just can't use it you know what i
mean so i guess they rolled me over and
who knows i don't really remember i
don't remember the rest of it but then
so i couldn't really shoot or do
anything and then it was also even that
did you see that that there was yeah
look at this there yeah she was all
right i did there is a clip of me uh as
soon as i was feeling better and i moved
into um the house that had the uh half
court i was like you know let's just see
like free throws are like my thing let's
see how many i can do in a row and i did
post it on instagram i think i did do 14
in a row
i think i did get 14 a row in yeah
because when you get higher and higher
in terms of like the competitive uh
teams as uh you know
me you have to be good at shooting
because you're not going to be as fast
you're not going to be sure did the dude
go with you to the hospital a lot of
stuff that kind of put a damper on the
weekend i would assume
i don't i was trying no he didn't want
to hear much about it
really i told you he shouldn't have
brought her yeah yeah yeah all he
thought things like your right hand
doesn't work
[Laughter]
back on raya
all right oh that's the rich person oh
that is the 89 dating app
no it's the it's the douchebag yeah it's
it's the people that say they're rich
and catfish why i'm on tinder dating app
but no that i think in the beginning
yeah raya was like very exclusive
yeah now it's like just how many bozos
there's a lot of man buns and v-necks
and
how about that feel
that's top quality cbd right there you
want to keep your head clear you want to
stay focused you want to have a good
time get yourself a little bit of fields
they have an easy membership program no
fuss no must get you the fantastic cbd
you need to power you through your day
yeah guys if you haven't tried cbd it
was a game changer for me and my anxiety
rushing through the city
it just kind of
takes that edge off turns the volume
down a little bit reduces anxiety pain
sleeplessness the whole nine yards it's
shipped direct to your doorstep and only
a few days feels is the new natural
healthy better way to feel better um you
place a few drops of fields under your
tongue there you go and feel the
difference within minutes there's no
hangover no addiction no none of that uh
if you need a dose to chill on the go
pop one of feels new cbd infused mints
for clear-headed feeling there you go
let the day wash away with a little bit
of feed little feels like uh that's
fantastic i started using feels years
ago before we even started the podcast
uh they send it to you the little
dosages you figure out what you like and
then bada bing bada boom you're on your
way become a member today by going to
feels.com garbage and you'll get fifty
percent off your first sort of
assistance shipping they're giving it
nuts all to cut that what are you gonna
do given the goddamn store away that's
fields f-e-a-l-s
dot com slash garbage to become a member
and get fifty percent off automatically
taking off your first order with free
shipping feels.com garbage do it try it
keep up with that butcher box put your
box put your box who butchered butcher
box butcher box we're gonna get some
listen it's grilling season bozo so what
do you want to do you want to go to the
supermarket and get meat that's pumped
full of hormones there's diapers in it
needles sticking out of it or do you
want top quality free range grass fed
grass vintage wild caught meat wow what
do you want to do yeah you like free
bacon because they're giving the [ __ ]
away
i don't know if that's this month but
everybody relax
uh every month butcher but you know what
put your boxes by this point
absolutely stupid i should have to
explain it to you but i will because
they're paying us too and i'm a big fan
of it every month put your boxes in
ground chuck
every month butcher box ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your home free shipping and continental
us no antibiotics no added hormones no
act fresh [ __ ] frozen for convenience
save time and energy on your next trip
to the grocery store you throw it in the
freezer when you're ready you defrost it
you throw it on the grill you got a
delicious meal for you and your family
the bridge and listen if you're a meat
rookie a grilling you don't know what's
going on you can go and you can
customize your own box or they know
whatever yeah let them do it that's what
they did to us wild caught salmon showed
up
cornish hens they got the whole nine
yards don't even start
uh
it's high quality meat delicious one
hundred percent grapefruit grass-fed
beef free-range chicken pork raised
crate free no crates it's not a crazy
crate not a crate why on the joint
seafood for less than six dollars per
meal on average what are we doing look
at that i mean look at that how many
times i got to tell you people get
summer sizzling started with the special
butcher box deal for our listeners free
bacon for life of your membership plus
ten dollars off cold hard cash that's
the h50 deal and some bacon what do you
what more do you eat in the world top
quality bacon too sign up today at
butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg to get
one pack of free bacon in every single
box for the life of your membership plus
ten dollars off your first order baby
that's codor
that's butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg
to claim this deal do it not bad
goodness yeah yeah okay what were the
vacations like as a kid uh rehoboth
beach maryland
that was the main thing so we but we
would stay in dewey beach or bethany
shout out to dewey dewey beach baby
and
ocean city ocean city maryland yes oh so
shitty ocean city we grew up going to
ocean city new jersey and then there
every philly family at some point got
somebody
one summer said let's go down ocean city
maryland and it's stunk
yeah it was like bizarro world it was
kind of the same thing
dewey beach knows exactly who they are
and it's [ __ ] fantastic shout out to
the starboard i think rehoboth's okay as
long as you don't go on any of the rides
yeah and have been uh vaccinated against
like um tetanus typhoid yeah i'm not
even talking kovan the boardwalk's
concrete that throws me off
that must be new more of a promenade
yeah you know where there where the
grotto's pizza is and the dolly's taffy
of course i do yeah grotto's pizza but
right around there do you remember the
gravatron of course remember that made
my bones on the [ __ ] ground i would i
would turn upside down yeah we would you
were the person that would get up and
turn i remember i was on it once because
we would go on it over and over like all
day over and over and over and we'd go
upside down and one time did you ever
have a kid puke on it i don't know
because the puke would go out and then
come right back
laughs pj's in the middle that's when
you take the picture last time i ever
went on so that was uh and then also we
would go to west virginia and in roanoke
virginia okay all right no disney world
anything like that i think we did uh
were you a busch gardens family
uh we definitely had a king's dominion
trip okay is that still around uh i
don't know i think it's still right
king's dominion and oh sorry well so my
mom's side of the oh oh my mom's side of
the family is texas so my mom is from a
place called sherman texas so kind of
like every other summer we would go to
sherman texas for a couple weeks and we
would go to the six flags over texas but
that's the original right that's the
that is the original that is the one
that their main claim to fame is that
they have the only wooden roller coaster
left in the world and what's so quote
fun about it is that when you're on it
it shakes yeah you think you're gonna
die psychotic yeah i've been on the
cyclone in coney island
yeah so that those but not not a ton of
those i like i never went to disney
world until i went to la and hung out
with adults
okay adults are like i want to go to
disney world like you're 40. yeah disney
adults are weird it's wild to me all
right let's get it what was the
supermarket growing up yeah where'd you
go safeway
okay
[Laughter]
you have to put safe in your title yeah
hey we swear to god it's all right
you're not you're not gonna get stabbed
just don't look at anybody yeah
and then don't wear red or blue either
you'll be the lights are always blinking
in those places i don't like them and
then in virginia it was kroger food lion
kroger all right food line got a little
hemmed up in the 80s i remember hemmed
up those just names or misplaced safeway
kroger and food lions mislabeling some
meat that was a little bit older than
you can't do that
you can't do that
you can't do that have you ever have you
ever shopped at that crazy expensive one
in la erwan of course yes that's where
you go now yes i don't go there now
regularly but i will go sometimes it's
like uh
um it's just for people that hate money
yeah you know what i mean but if you i'm
sorry no it's like it's like thirteen
dollars for like a juice are you going
to the store who's who's stocking or do
you have somebody going or are you
ordering what are you doing i do amazon
fresh okay am i allowed to do that yeah
what do you mean yeah okay yeah we want
you to flex as hard as possible but it's
also like that's not like oh it's not
like an exclusive club it's amazing no
it's a no it's the biggest company in
the world no i mean like am i am i
allowed to use um
no it's not i'm going to walmart.com is
that okay to say it's not i think people
think i'm elitist it's more like just
like using amazon these days is like
everyone's regardless of what they say
everybody's doing i know but everyone's
like oh you're like just bad for the
environment and you know jeff bezos but
um the uh uh i do go myself too all the
time because i like going to grocery
stores okay it's like my favorite thing
really so i'll go to the whole foods
near my house and then i actually my
favorite grocery store is trader joe's i
think it has the best food
is the [ __ ] best also the best flours
and the best dips always everything any
of their snacks that they come up with
dudes are phenomenal they're [ __ ]
peanut butter cups they're [ __ ]
caramel coated uh chocolates the whole
night the stoner elves that make their
snacks
are wild it's like salt and pepper
cheese flakes you're like who the [ __ ]
is coming up they're frozen they're
delicious and by the way they're um wine
selection is incredible yeah they know
what they're doing they used to they
used to carry something called two buck
chuck that became real yeah yeah that
was a big thing charles something i also
like that all the people that work there
seem like they're like going through
something
[Laughter]
you know writing an album you know what
i'm saying because tj's is like i think
they treat their employees pretty well
yeah they do so i think it's like people
that are not just like uh last i think
they they're like going through a
divorce they're like just their sister
died and they just had to adopt four
kids out of no like they're all people
they're all in it about going trying to
plow and go forward they're really
painting a picture when you're in there
like you know people are treated for
kids it's like sometimes like people you
know you're like oh hey i haven't seen
you in a while like it's not an
embarrassing job not at all like the guy
from um fresh prince of spell oh i
thought it was french prince of smelly i
think he said
and it was the wrong show
this girl's bonkos it was the cosby show
i know how to make hit shows uh it was
it was she does would you not watch that
i mean would you watch it or would you
watch him um but uh so yeah so it's like
they're all they're all kind of like
adults that are actually yeah is it is
it's more like a career like uh yeah
yeah
top shelf all right pretty good
let's see
uh have you ever tried to start the wave
at a sporting event
can i tell you something
a hundred percent of the time always um
yes
i'm like you know uh what are the
australian shepherds that need to herd
the border collies yeah i at sporting
events like need everyone to be on this
sale i'm like guys we have to do what i
want to do like a
she's got a sign up yes
yes have you ever been kicked out of a
sporting event
uh have i ever been kicked out of a
sporting event have ever been kicked no
i've been kicked out of a movie theater
nice for what police
because i was with how old are you um
two weeks ago it was truly it was uh
probably for uh a year and a half for
the pandemic maybe
what the [ __ ] oh yeah i went a friend of
mine i had never had edibles
[Laughter]
now we're talking
it was like a cookie it was like a
cookie and we went to see gone girl
whenever that came out that'll [ __ ] you
up there's a twist and turns
did i kill her i don't know what's
happening that movie was wild and it
wasn't just a conceit like women are
crazy yes that's every movie but the
cast
the casting was so wide i mean david
fincher i mean one of the greatest
filmmakers mine hunter one
genius he can get anyone he wants to be
in his movies and so his casting is so
specific and he like stunts on everyone
when he casts just to [ __ ] with you so i
had taken an edible and everything was
fine i'm enjoying the movie and then all
of a sudden
i see tyler perry in the movie
and i just don't i'm not sure
is this medea what the [ __ ] going on
do you know what i'm saying at the time
the [ __ ] at the time tyler perry being
in a david fincher drama was a little
wild sure he was obviously so
him so what'd you do he was trying to
make it campy he was trying to make it
fun he was trying to make it like you
know and and also like introducing punch
the guy next to me no i just was like
because i i started getting paranoid and
i my friend that i was with i was uh
john i was like do you see tyler perry
and he was like yeah that's tyler perry
right he didn't really know tyler perry
that well so he's like yeah i think so
and so i'm already like uh oh you don't
and i i went and i asked almost everyone
in the movie theater like oh my god
i was like did you see tyler i just want
to confirm that i'm not so high that i'm
losing my mind and then as soon as i
felt better about the tyler perry thing
then neil patrick harris comes on to
play the straight guy that's the rapist
and i was like i i now i gotta ask i
heard it all i was like what's the
projection
i was do you guys see neil patrick so i
was just i wasn't me i was just trying
to corroborate with everyone so you
ruined the movie for everybody that was
they were just like ma'am you can come
back like to the next showing when can
you please it's too high to sit here
hey lady come back when you can handle
your edibles all right
it's a pretty common thing but yeah so i
was asked to leave jeez [ __ ] that's wild
well you sneak snacks into a movie
theater or will you buy them there
i like to buy them there
nice i like to buy them there the
popcorn you can only buy there sure you
get a soda there what's your go-to soda
yeah i'm just if they if they don't have
diet dr pepper i will bring my own wow i
hadn't i had to die dr pepper today
nothing there is nothing there's nothing
like an ice cold dr pepper can i t do
you know do you know what dr pepper is
flavored after you know what's supposed
to taste like wait i do know this um
[ __ ] correct me if i'm wrong you're
right it's something specific i just
don't know i believe it's fig
figure dates but i think it's big it's
yes it's something along those lines is
that weird to think that's good
i like to figure a date on my cheese
board
dude when i was in college i almost
exclusively ate dried figs nice
they have the wheels of figs you ever
seen those in the supermarkets they have
them everywhere but okay
they shouldn't have a safe way or food
lion
the first time you made it to a major
city you're like holy [ __ ] like they
have wawa you [ __ ]
okay yeah so um
yes so dr pepper i was i'm also
i'm also a diet sun kissed person whoa
okay so sometimes i'll bring a couple
drinks diet sun kissed is a dirtbag
drink though
some kisses all right what was what were
the lunch situations going to school
when you were a kid sure so much you do
my mom worked at bloomingdale's and so
she would bring home the bags so it
would say little brown bag yup that's
what's like the
richest medium brown bag big big brown
bags yes which if you shopped at
bloomingdale's it was rich as [ __ ] if
you worked there and just stole the bags
if you got some old meatloaf in there
yeah exactly so i would go to school
those little pokers in it
how you guys doing things are good on
the farm how to kill a horse this
morning
i would bring you anybody see my guinea
pig
[Laughter]
i remember my lunches when i when i
lived in roanoke
we had uh every day of the week was a
different fast food restaurant so that
was like monday night at school at
school
catholic royal catholic school when i
was
i'm 39
uh when i was
10 11 12 13 14 it was monday was pizza
hut tuesday taco bell wednesday
wednesday's checkers they would bring it
in oh yeah you would order in the
morning and then you would get it for
lunch
what wild i know looking back that's
crazy go to school there now i don't
know
they must do his eligibility like who
they have a football team down here must
have changed it i mean they might that's
yeah they say that's not there's no way
they fed kids fast food every single day
every day that's [ __ ] awesome it's
crazy to think about that now and then
when i was uh bringing bag lunch to
school all i really remember i there
were a lot of lunchables that was a big
big
i know what
it was trash
yeah but like sure i get it it's i mean
as a kid for a kid it's a dream but yes
yes and so but i do remember a lot of
like
a bagel
that just wrapped in saran wrap
do you know what i mean you would buy or
you would i guess my mom would make
there was just like a bagel wrapped in
saran wrap with like cream cheese like i
remember that was like because you know
you would go to you everyone would pull
out their lunch and it was basically
just a parenting competition like you
would like open your lunch my mom bless
her she would put crazy sometimes she
would have like she had friends over she
was very like social there would just be
like a steamed artichoke like no one
like
like a receipt for a scarf
[Music]
because she would do the events at
bloomingdale so she would bring home
whatever was left over so sometimes in
my three day old deviled eggs and [ __ ]
it was just like like a thing of brie
cheese like what is this like just a
rind yeah and then my dad you know
worked at that hotel in west virginia so
he would bring food home and big tim
[ __ ] go to school with a waffle maker
salisbury steak
so i would bring some it doesn't carry
well it would bring stalls very sticky
what even is salisbury steak
hamburger
steak or whatever it was and then
chicken fried steak chicken fried steak
okay oh damn it's pretty cool so i'd
bring that in
no she's an eight-year-old eating
chicken-fried steak in west virginia
out of a sephora yeah yeah so jesus
riddle wrapped in a rhyme here
now we're getting somewhere anyone in
your family have a standalone hot tub or
an above ground pool uh yes so in texas
sherman texas my aunt sandy had the
above ground pool you have to get in a
ladder or the whole thing any magicians
in the family
um
no
any beekeepers
no
no but i am
what this isn't good
i gotta nest the hornets
i do have so many bees where i live
because i'm the last um water source for
like 160 acres for the bees so i'm like
what i know so i like remove the queens
and try to like humanely like like you
yourself or you hire somebody well i've
hired someone that helped me know how to
do it and then i'm gonna i'm gonna start
getting hives and like having bees
that's pretty cool but because my
friends come over with their kids and
they're covered in bees like i can't i
can't
do this they're all cody's got a bee
suit on but they they can't even eat
peanuts much less beans
yeah
go toe-to-toe with the queen exactly so
i am gonna have bees soon but how do you
know that you're that your property is
the only source of water for a hundred
and how many acres because uh that's
pretty classy but you know that that is
uh
interesting
right that means there's not a lot of
people close to you that's correct
really mm-hmm i'm in the end of a
cul-de-sac uh in a place called
basically topanga canyon which is why i
moved there i mean i wasn't planning on
staying out you have a gate in front of
your house you know what i need i need a
holler because
what's a holler
um west virginia virginia of hollers
which is like you're in mountains like i
need to feel like i'm in um i got it
okay my like west virginia ancestor do
you have a gate at the house yes really
is it like a what what is it like a pad
or it's like a keypad so i'm in a uh uh
there's like four houses in my in the
cul-de-sac and there's a gate and then
is there a gate to get into the
cul-de-sac and then there's another gate
to get into your house
that's
right knew this was going to count
against me this is i mean this is good
it's good no i have people today but
it's not so much about keeping people
out as it's keeping my people
can't the bees get away don't steal my
queen i swear to god i need the honey
ah you're all [ __ ] you're something
else you have pit bulls
yes how many dogs you have a lot don't
you which pit bulls are like i i
remember tim mentioned something about
you having pit bulls yes yes so i've got
um a great dane uh staffy pit a
ridgeback pit um just got yeah uh i have
many of them
you know janna's saved my life once yeah
yana stayed at my house a couple months
ago can you get bit to oh did he or me
well yeah i've got that finger is pretty
much jacked this finger and then this
ear was bitten off whoa by your dogs
well this was a dog that i was fostering
that was i was like rehabilitating to
rehome so i'll i'll take dogs that were
in the dog fighting um morass in la and
try to rescue them can you see it though
can i see it i'm trying not to look at
it
classy
and trashy all at the same time your
heart's in the right place it's a dog
bite on your ear what the [ __ ] yeah
that's the first time no it was you're
an executive producer for guys
you created television it was hanging
off the side of my head
hey
collect more bees but that's very sweet
that you do that it's i mean look i just
rescued a dog myself yeah oh yeah what
kind uh pitbull they lied to me they
said it was a shepherd lab did the dna
destiny
well there's no such thing
as a chihuahua
okay it's a coyote i need
some help
okay
you got to pull at the house now yes hot
tub yes stone
around it yeah salt water fresh water
ozone
what the [ __ ] is that what that is i had
a lawn go get water from that's from
mars it's half chlorine what are they
found on mars the only pool of moon
water
it's only scientology blessed water
no it's half salt water half chlorine
okay cool yeah i believe i believe
that's what it's called or or sometimes
when i have these conversations i go my
pool guy scammed me yeah yeah that's not
a real thing he saw two gates it was
like this i can pull the wool over here
it's only an extra six grand a month uh
it's filled with dyed sunkist
so it's like a little bit of both
because um uh you don't want all the
algae in the [ __ ] yes i i was just
watching a show where they talked about
that okay
nice nice nice okay what's the garage
situation at the house the garage i have
converted into a gym okay and put dog
crates in it nice how many cars
could it be two car garage three-car
garage four
four the garage that it could is a
four-car garage damn you have a
refrigerator in there yes you got soda i
put the refrigerator in there that's
cool when i bought the house there was
no refrigerator in the garage which was
i found disgusting and classless okay
and
the truck so in texas you and and in
virginia dc we didn't have this but you
always have a second fridge 100 for the
garage for the bluebell ice cream for
the meat for leftovers beers yeah
exactly the peppers it's like the drink
fridge and the leftover bread yeah you
have like four cakes from people's
weddings to eat in your first
anniversary that you never get to which
we we've done that was one of the
original questions of the show when at
the impetus of the show the garage
garage
and it is inherently it's great it's
convenient but it's inherently trashy
because it was always you got a new
fridge inside and go it's a trash it's a
trashy mentality like we can't throw
away this fridge of course just plug it
into the garage oh yeah my family's uh
in texas and in um virginia even when
you're done with a car you just leave it
on the front lawn
you don't throw the idea of throwing
anything away parts baby you know but
also in uh texas it was also not the
fridge that was too open it was a square
that you it was like what animal it's
like what murderers put body parts you
know it's a chest fridge and it's all
ice cream okay shout out to the ice box
yeah i like it i like it um
but also fridge uh garage fridge what
color
they're typically what the trash ones
them
in your stainless steel you have a
double opening mine is black whirlpool
what's ropel whirlpool oh
you don't have you're not you're not
banging with a sub z out there and no no
it's just a black whirlpool and you can
get ice uh
crushed ice and a drink from it what are
you what are you batting with inside
that stainless steel you got a sub z in
the house yes if you have a jewel did
you redo this joint now did you did you
gut it and hook it up we did it yeah
i've seen instagram stories it's a nice
place it is it is it's it's very uh
beautiful but i actually wanted to make
it look older so a lot of people don't
maybe appreciate that like it looks like
an old like i i basically said i wanted
to look like um like a
rehab in spain
like it's very cozy fireplaces
everywhere like it's okay but it was
made less modern like like a football
player or something owned it before me
and it was all these like like drippy
ass like um fireplaces with the crystals
that turned lime green and purple gotcha
i kind of made it more lo-fi you have an
island in the kitchen yes nice and what
is the refrigerator is it a sub-z
viking what are you viking i would have
[ __ ] i don't know
but it's it's pretty good is it open
like that yes and then
we have a you know what it is i covered
it so it looks like a cabinet it looks
like a cabinet holy [ __ ] i know
that's that is that is luxury i
basically was like if i can just not see
all the brands of everything or just
seeing my own clutter so the two things
on the other side of the fridge you know
that would be shelves of like pantry and
[ __ ] has doors so you can just instead
of having to clean it you can just close
two doors i like it and it's gone are
any of the bookcases doors yeah do you
have any like trap doors where you're
like pull this [ __ ] candle yeah you
got a panic room or anything
every room i'm in is a pamper
um
i don't have that
i don't have that but i did want to look
at a house in la that did and i was like
this is where the kids get [ __ ] yeah i
remember being like i cannot buy this
house i don't i don't need to have
secret places in my own home like who
like that's sketchy to me but i did uh
they did tell me to get a panic room and
it was gonna cost all this money and i
was like
that bill makes me panic so i'm fine
okay all right any fish tanks in the
house now no but i really want one have
you held a turtle in the last 365 days
yes
why also by the way the fish tank is
kind of a stupid story y'all know byron
allen of course yeah so byron you know
remember that comics unleashed where
everyone was sitting around and doing
you know and there was a shark in the
back there was a shark tank in the back
it was a tank with just one shark and he
stopped shooting the show but he has
this giant studio and i saw the shark in
there one day and i asked people i was
like what's up with the shark like i
just asked some random person and i was
like does he need someone to like take
it like i i wouldn't stop the show do
you have a shark well no it was like it
was in byron allen's like old studio and
i was there for something else and i was
like does he and then a month later or
something he texts me because i'm like
asking him i'm like i'm happy to take it
and he was like uh just fyi i want to
keep my shark like there's no it's like
upsetting the life of you living by
right now and texted you hey sorry i'm
keeping the show what are you ace
ventura
so i really thought for a while that i
was going to inherit that shark but i
was talking about inheriting a shark all
right it's not like
kidnapped kidnap i know so i would love
to have fish around uh what was the
other one
uh i don't know you just freaked me out
with the steel and the shark thing to be
honest
um fishing turtles turtles why'd you
have a turtle friend of mine well i
have any natural water in your property
no i live in california there's no water
[Music]
the woolsey fires happened um i do i
work with the lafd to do volunteer like
equine evacuation and stuff so i there
were all these turtles that need to be
moved like big ones and then i have some
friends that have a lot of people uh
have those because turtles are actually
a great pet because they live for so
long but you do have to put them in your
will they might outlive you oh they're
all yeah yeah they're like 100 years
older they're incredible it's pretty
cool i love them you're an animal lover
yes it's pretty classy yeah
i just had to get a rabies shot
that's not so classy what bit you
well turtle
now
no i was in uh in my house so i have
this like new puppy that has to go out
all the time four o'clock i open the
door uh the sliding glass doors i'm
really groggy and then my big dog goes
and the puppy goes and i instantly just
hear like like it's dark i can't see
what's going on i'm like okay coyotes
are in the yard they're always in you
know out in l.a coyotes the coyotes and
then i just closed my eyes and just put
my hands in the melee and i felt of the
coyote and the dog well i saw that it
was a raccoon i as soon as i saw it was
wrecked bit by a raccoon okay
what are we doing toby cutting
it do we need to get tested for anything
by the way oh [ __ ] you just touched me
i'm foaming out the mouth here
so
they uh well this is by the way also two
weeks after i was in the hamptons with
tim dillon and found a tick on my [ __ ]
so i had to go on the lyme disease
medication for two weeks so um
half of the reason i couldn't understand
was god i was obnoxious from the lyme
disease [ __ ] so i go out i'm breaking up
this fight between raccoons and the dogs
i do feel what i believe to be a baby
raccoon just run up my leg grab my
shorts so i felt it i just thought it
was funny and whatever sounds hilarious
i say yeah i'm like okay that was just a
it was just a baby raccoon no problem
not a coyote everything's fine i do have
some scratches on me but that could be
from anything and so my dude is a
veterinarian and he like lost his lost
his mind and he was like you have to go
get a vaccine because the next day the
coyote was in the tree outside my deck
now do kai i mean sorry raccoon how do
raccoons sleep do you know
i don't know it was hanging over a
branch it looked like it was dead so i'm
like poking at it that's a pop what do
you do and then it looks at me so i mean
so i'm hitting it with a wiffle ball
so it looks at me and it's kind of like
not i can't get it to move it's moving
really slow i call animal control and i
was like hey this is la animal control
for you i was like there's a raccoon in
the tree and she's like yeah that's
where they live and i was like okay well
i kind of it's acting very weird it
might have rabies can someone you know
come remove it and she goes i'm not
gonna remove an animal from its home how
about hey it [ __ ] jacked me in the
middle of the night when i let the dogs
out i want to open with that and then
not it's taking a nap on the front porch
also whitney was like hey next time
you're not like stay at my house
absolutely not i keep trying to get them
to stay in my house stay in my place
not the ladies i'll tell you these
stories and that's my dog i'm sharing a
room with a portuguese man of war no
thank you and then she goes great she
goes well it might be acting weird
because in la a lot of people are
testing their cocaine for fentanyl and
if it tests positive they flush it down
the toilet so it might just have drank
l.a water and is on fentanyl what the
[ __ ]
that's a that's a big series of events
for
maybe to guess the raccoons [ __ ] so
you got bit by a raccoon oh it was i
scratched it scratched me
and you had and you you're
so i'm on my third uh shot of the rabies
shot yes
damn dude that's a [ __ ]
tarzana er they were like we've never
seen this we've seen it with bats but
never with raccoons
yeah the [ __ ] going on out there yeah
wild chat i was thinking about moving
out of the city i don't think so no just
don't i mean i don't know how y'all deal
with this lyme disease [ __ ] i don't even
know what you're talking about lyme
disease everyone that like goes to the
hamptons and is rich in connecticut and
[ __ ] they all have lyme disease
you think we're going to the hamptons
the wild with new jersey man shout out
to it shout out to saved pizza i went to
temple i'm not going to the hamptons
oh
but you're right you're go you're
cavorting with people in the city that
go to the hamptons in connecticut you're
never fighting raccoons in your backyard
what are you talking about
i feel like everyone in i guess well
what's up state you don't go to
like
rye i don't know
it just seems like everyone you're the
only person i noticed i'm like you're
the only person that's ever i've been
living here for 10 years the only person
to go what are you doing about the lyme
disease i have no idea really yeah and
you just mentioned five of the most
deadliest animals in your backyard
all this time where were the what were
the bees doing this whole thing if
you're not not enter not helping me oh
my god i'm i mean i'm okay you're done
i'm good yeah i got i got i got all the
evidence i need yeah we do
do you like banana pudding
if it none of this is going to save you
i don't know why i mean
if it comes give me a million dollars
and maybe i'll say you're classy if it
comes in the pre things
like the little ones that are um are
attached like number six puddings are
attached shores snack packs snack packs
okay i don't like banana pudding
homemade in some bowl with someone
brings to the party with bananas around
the side like i don't want to i don't
know i'm part of your etsy page i was
thinking respect that i was thinking
more of a classy bakery that would have
not the [ __ ] hunt snack pack which is
where your mind goes those are
the fudge the those are great
did you what did you do for ice cream
growing up did you ever do the remember
the ice cream what didn't i do remember
the american flag ice creams it would be
red white and blue and then there was
one that was banana and chocolate no yes
you american flag ice cream
we had vanilla chocolate strawberry
never banana the firecracker the oh
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it was a square
and then it went square and then it kind
of got small and then yeah the fire
cracker is that what it was called i did
have banana in it they had a banana
chocolate one that was my [ __ ] i love
[ __ ] banana ice cream goddamn and it
[ __ ] up my life because my mom used to
tell me that when the ice cream truck
played music that meant it was out
that's a common thing just real quick
just a couple of things i'd like to know
do you pee in the shower
no really i have but not
regularly it's got to be a it's a rough
day yeah brush your teeth in the shower
no
nine times a week to your floss
oh god that is
like one or two okay it's bad do you
have a could you have a cup in the in
your bathroom on the sink like that for
a toothpaste or sorry for a toothbrush
not that you drink out of no do you
bring a glass of water to bed with you
when you go to sleep it's like a ba it's
like a like
you bring a bottle away
how many pillows do you use when you
sleep uh
um one and a half so one behind your
head and then there's this thing called
coyote
there's something called a sleep crown
that i use that i put over my head what
the [ __ ] is a sleep crown i don't know
but she's crazy
i love it i want to feel like a queen
when i'm sleeping it's like give me my
crown it's a thing that you just put
over and it makes your face
yeah and it muffles the sound gotcha i
gotcha that's awesome and i take it on
the road with me do you use your a phone
as an alarm clock in the morning do you
have an alarm clock in your room uh
phone is an alarm clock okay all right
what's your uber rating oh [ __ ] i i got
dinked bad i don't know i should check i
did i didn't want you traveling with
bees i had
is it okay if my queen comes with me i
need to transport the queen
hey you guys
you guys do squirrels what's the deal a
squirrel sit in the front seat is it
weird that i always ask if i can drive
like you mind
i would have to check hold on hold on
because i had one situation with an uber
driver that was a it was uberx
and this was before masks and everything
and i guess uberx is kind of just people
that are going about their day like
and she did stop
on two personal like errands yeah i just
i just had a guy stop for gas the other
day it was wild two errands i just gotta
have dinner real quick i literally
pulled over to like get out and like get
something from i feel like i was being
pretty cool about it and then i asked
her i was like just curious like how
like
how long like
like will i ever get are you getting a
full order in the grocery store it's
just 10 items or less what's this dude
do you have an appointment at the er
or are we just waiting like did you do
no i got a chance yeah at the apple
store like did you schedule ahead of
time and then she was she got really
defensive with me and she's like just
you know like uberx like this is people
that are like going about their day like
this isn't uber xl or uber black oh i
didn't know that yeah but i think sh we
were yeah it was not real and then i
asked her yeah i don't think that is
real and then she was like it was more
leg room she was like she's like if you
have a problem you can just get out and
i was like okay like maybe i should so
she like dropped like got off the
freeway and like dropped me off oh what
a dick i know it was just like a weird
thing and i'm sure she was shitty but
how do i find my um
profile account oh god if this is bad oh
my god i thought it said one-third i was
like oh god
no no
edit uber rating yes please credit card
number rating rate
[ __ ] activity i don't know home oh right
here account uh-oh rating well go to my
pro four point six one it's not that
good that's not good i'm not good it's
out of five yeah but that's still yeah
that means that's bad huh
just as a preliminary event and where i
live there's bad wi-fi right at the gate
and every time i go out the uber's i've
been driving around there's no wi-fi i
hate you and they hate me and then
there's no wi-fi and then i'll always
tell them like oh there's no wi-fi here
so if you if you just keep going and
take a right and then i'm telling them
how to drive but otherwise they're gonna
have to know why so i'm already like a
i was going to say a word that i think
i'm not allowed to say on youtube you
have you have a car yourself right yes
how many cars do you have one just one
car one yeah okay tesla
no uh range rover
that's what i want to get is that is the
house you have in cali the only house
that you own or do you have other
properties there's a [ __ ] hotel bozo
well i don't own that but yes
i just said no i mean someone else is uh
paying for it all but um uh i have a
mover and shake or this i did have a
tesla i didn't i had it for a long time
i had teslas for a long time and then i
just i couldn't anymore um because you
really have to
be okay with
everything after four o'clock
just not getting there okay i mean
because like if you're in traffic if you
have ac on if you have gps sure like you
can think you have 200 miles and then if
you have ac and make two phone calls
you're at 20 miles like it's up text to
me so the thing is [ __ ] i know the
things [ __ ] so having a car with
night and weekends on it i don't that's
it like i'm out of minutes man i can't
make it tesla is rich people's second
car you know what i mean it's not a
gotcha i don't think it's like a like it
can fart and dance but it can't like get
you to your destination um so yeah i
have a range rover which i love
okay well i do want to get a truck uh it
is black you gotta go black right
vacation house anywhere anything like
that just the one house out out there
what's a vacation look like for you now
what do you do you just got you just
shot the special it's released
santorini what are you doing
oh i this is so
you're not gonna believe me but i
i have not been on a vacation in a while
because i like just staying home and not
because we tour so much it's like i
don't have to go be in a hotel you know
um and uh i did try to do a vacation in
the hamptons because tim dillon was
there i was doing a show there i was
like let me stay a couple days
i don't understand why that's right you
stay at the house with timmy d you get
your own place i had my brother-in-law
has a place there nice okay and we were
actually pretty close to each other okay
but it was not relaxing in the slightest
you got kicks all over you yeah and you
have to go to like
you it's like um
all the homes are like 200 million
dollar gingerbread houses they're not
fancy it's not fantastic thing about the
tim is school it's like you don't flash
the money why are we pretending yeah
that's what really rich people do they
want to protect money that's them
slumming it why do i feel like i'm in a
shitty like uh theater production of the
crucible like why can't we just have
luck like i have to go to a fruit stand
to get to pick from two peaches and all
of the all the restaurants and and um
[ __ ] where you get your food are run by
like trust fund kids that they're only
doing that job because their rich ass
parents are like making them like learn
the value so they're like like they
don't they know they have a trust fund
like the whole thing was very speech
yeah yeah of course
there's no wi-fi in the trash like i'm
like this i don't get it um
but come down to wildwood new jersey
yeah shout out to wildwood new jersey
you can stay at our place any time and
then i did uh my niece was in town for a
lacrosse tournament so i did go to
baltimore for a couple days okay we went
to the esp not espn zone dave and
busters nice all right it was pretty
pleasant really are a dirtbag yeah
i mean
something else you know what i did go to
big sur which is like northern
california it's like on the cliffs
really really beautiful like uh
would you break out there
[Laughter]
broke my hip
dolphin had a red also by the way below
4.7 is a bad uber rating so
um do you think that one
time yeah i had that two of the man's
[ __ ] jacket it's a couple of times it
jams you up it's gotta be a couple
mine's not good can i say something else
every time i get into an uber in
where was i just where was i just i
guess in la it says mask required right
and you'd have to check matt like why
i'm wearing a mask yeah well they do
that here but nobody's wearing them i'll
say then you get in the driver doesn't
have a mask on and then you're like oh
is it cool if i and they're like oh yeah
you don't do i get dinged for that
sometimes they do if they want to be a
[ __ ] they do we were on the road
somewhere and we didn't put man i
thought whatever he did i don't know he
wasn't wearing one either yeah and so
back when i got back to new york in
order to confirm the uber in order in
order to confirm the driver i had to
take a picture i had to take a selfie of
myself and send it to the driver of me
wearing a mask crazy that's a sex thing
yeah
that was that and nothing i'm here for
it
um also one one thing we always ask
everybody if you're going to a wedding
right you're going to a friend's wedding
white dress long white dress
and i kiss the groom first
what's the envelope looking like what
are you giving as a gift
cash-wise
oh i usually do the registry okay okay i
do i try to do
double the
i know my girl it depends if it's my guy
friend or my girlfriend
and it depends andrew schultz andrew
schultz i i what i did for them was uh
i don't think i did anything from the
registry because it was all by the time
i got to it it was like a little
yeah his whole registry was just his own
specials it was weird
new special we love chelsea i'm gonna
see him tomorrow um but uh i did i
actually got his wife uh a makeup artist
for the day
um classy
that's pretty close you know because
clown makeup but i know it was it was
blackface uh it was justin trudeau's
blackface guy um and then i got her some
like funny books like about marriage
from like the 50s or something like i
like very cute
cool i like vintage books about about
that kind of [ __ ] like yeah
she does walk in both worlds she has
bees all right
shut up she's trash she fostered a dog
and then sent it out to the world with a
taste for human blood she may or may not
have been bitten by a raccoon she's
almost currently on a rabies shop [ __ ]
up jesus christ the one that actually
the one that bit my ear off that was i
afterwards it took him to get an
aggression test and it turns out he's
just yeah i got news for you he got a
1400
he's going to pen next fall holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
my god
that's it wrap it up i mean really quick
though can i ask you guys there's two
just even if we're done did you ever
have when you would go into the uh your
uh refrigerator at home when you would
see a country croc like butter thing
like yeah did not know what was going to
be gravy meatballs yeah it could be
meatballs pimento cheese yeah like
philadelphia cream cheese what it was
all about
okay sometimes you would get real upset
because i wouldn't think and i'd have
like a bagel already toasted i like pop
open the butter and it was you know just
corn
do you all remember royal cola
i by the way uh recently had a fresh guy
what oh
why did that go away i don't know i feel
like rc cola could come back though
because so many it's like it would be i
feel like it would be cool again because
so like our generation grew up on it so
it'd be like uh you know a novelty by a
little bit fresca started to regain some
heat in the early 2000s when people
started using it as a mixer people i
just had the vodka and the fresca that's
just they started really going that
sounds delicious yeah they were kind of
the precursor to like the white claws
and all that [ __ ] now well yeah
because but also remember because in
west virginia roanoke there was a and it
kind of hasn't gone away because i went
back to west virginia recently they're
still on that mountain dew [ __ ] horse
there's new mountain dews i just saw
that there's a yeah there's a cherry and
all sorts of like they're not they
haven't gone anywhere code red you got
they've been stronger they also started
getting into the hearts the the
they have hard mountain dew too with
booze in it really yeah they just came
out with that now we're talking and now
we're talking about and then there was
jolt
twice the it was like you know twice the
caffeine it's like drinking eight cups
of coffee like was that made like
illegal because i think for local was
taken off well that was because the cafe
they had to re-uh
engineer no re-engineer the
whatever was in for loco because it was
[ __ ] people up it was the caffeine
start doing weird it was like similar to
when [ __ ]
vodka red bulls dropped that was a game
changer right right that was my
stimulants and the [ __ ] booze did you
ever as a uh you know whatever teen uh
preteen
ever see the same band more than once
uh yeah if we the steve miller band
would come to the manned music center
like nine times a year it felt like but
we never went in we would just hang out
in the parking lot it isn't funny to go
think back to like now that you're
performers going like oh steve miller
was at that casino near me he had
probably had a bad divorce yeah yeah you
start thinking of the venues you're like
no one loves touring that like as an
adult you're like oh that guy didn't
had
pay
his
that like he was in a jam that was a
paycheck yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
tough
there's no other reason for him to come
nine times yeah
no never that the first concert i did go
to was meat loaf though when i was like
nine
my mom took the family to see meatloaf
what was your first time [ __ ] up my
first concert was not uh one that i
picked but it was duran duran that's not
bad
i was like my dad like was going with
and surprised me and it like i loved it
but i didn't quite know who they were
yet but that made me obsessed with them
uh paula abdul was big for me that's
nice
actually she was hot as [ __ ] back then
and then later once i actually like
understood whatever i definitely
followed dave matthews to a couple oh
ouch
man
when you hear that though when you like
what like how old were you
eleven eleven yeah eleven twelve and
you're you're in the parking lot to the
dmv yeah it was that was the nitrous
tank
hippie crackers see it but in in
virginia dave matthews fans were [ __ ]
nerds like they were maybe stone they
were like people that like
fish was in europe you know what i mean
so they would have but i definitely who
didn't
i don't know hooty and the blowfish dave
matthews like they toured together for a
while i definitely like went to south
carolina
with my like white braided bracelet or
something you ever go on vacation and
come back with braids like down to like
jamaica or anything like that i see what
you're doing and i'm not going to let
you do it
i know how to not get canceled but no
actually no i had adam pally uh
hilarious actor on my podcast the other
day and he was talking about how he did
that movie dirty grandpa or yeah
yeah yeah he was in florida the
producers like made him be in full
cornrows and he's like every time he
like had a drug situation they use that
photo he's like they use this
like it wasn't my idea like i didn't
mean like that i meant a couple of
braids oh i thought you about like
cornrows yeah no
you know what i mean like every you know
yes okay anklets toe ring the whole yes
how many tacks you got cause i see a
safety pin i have a cup two that are
white
this is an anchor upside down
that's white that's nothing do you see
that oh no i have that's from your table
but do you see it's written i love you
right there in white oh kind of see it
that was my way of going like let me see
if i'm just being invisible ink type
stuff well let me see if i'm like being
a basic [ __ ] and just like want a
tattoo let me just like do this and if i
like it enough we'll go gradually
they're under a black light stack
oh that's strange treasure map or
something and then i have two other ones
a safety pin in my horse's name
okay
you decorate the house for christmas i
feel like i'm really throwing up it's a
lot it's a lot is this what you expected
uh uh no not quite uh-uh i
she's going to be super classy which you
do have elements of that okay however
but it's like funny it's like you come
here in the nice car with the chauffeur
but you're doing it for paid promotion
you know what i mean yeah i know it's
like you're currently under rabies
treatment that's a fair state it's a
first that's a proper first yeah can i
wait i will go wait at the er it's not a
doctor it's the er damn i literally like
do you decorate the house for christmas
like a
psycho like a like a woman who lost two
children at the time on christmas on
christmas at the lake i colored lights
or white lights oh colored all the way
but but but but wait no i'm sorry no no
no no white white white white okay never
colored lights ever ever ever okay
growing up we had the ones that were
colored and there was a glass light and
there was liquid in it that would bubble
up do you remember those no they would
they would but they were so lamps and
christmas that's exactly like mini lava
lamps i don't do uh colored lights white
lights but the whole rest of the tree is
chaos it's only so i can make the whole
rest of the tree tinsel
no real tree or fake tree
real tree okay good but there is a fake
tree there is a fake tree that i just
bought that i'm so excited about where'd
you buy it um online it's a website
called
uh
bradford exchange so right now it's july
and i've bought my christmas tree that
did it for now you're going fake this
year
well once i see how big this is
i'll know i'm not on your wi-fi but
you'll see in a second this is what i'm
gonna
have this year i'm very excited about it
cool
is that expensive this is it's yeah you
do the four easy installments i don't
understand why 1050. i don't know why
you don't do anything like that do you
installments do you have any
installments going on right now uh
sometimes i see that a firm on the
bottom or whatever yes yeah like
i
they gotta be killing it man i'm like on
every [ __ ] website no if i can't pay
all up front i probably shouldn't buy it
what kind of credit card you you banging
with i do okay i can't really show this
to you but it's it's a tree with a bunch
of wolves all the ornaments are just
wolves do you see that yeah that's no
good
once you put down the backyard to keep
the actual wolves away
my tree i go very big i have a tree
decorating party it's a whole thing i
never celebrated um christmas for a long
time because it was you know
just not fun growing up when you have a
lot of divorce i got you your christmas
you go to nine different houses and one
day it's not fun i understand so i'm
trying to bring
it's a new thing for me to decorate hard
okay i like it
yeah yeah i see
yeah he has a wolf christmas tree
hey i love christmas i get in the spirit
and there was like 15 wolves on that
thing but also i love astrology
you decorate the house for halloween uh
actually kill a guy in the living room
actually no i did it one time when i
lived in a place in l.a called studio
city i was so it was the first time i
was like a homeowner i got all this
candy i tried to undo all the wrong
things that were done to me as a child
as a candy giver like no [ __ ] apples
no toothbrushes
none of that [ __ ] i got like paydays and
all the good no everybody no almond joy
none of that mounds [ __ ] like i killed
it with the candy i dressed up as a
superwoman and not one child came to not
one
because in la there's lots of hills and
they just none of that so
whatever everyone already thinks i'd
like drink baby blood but i would
i open the door and i'd be like hey guys
i have candy i'm like chasing chicken
children down the street being like i've
got good candy and no one's dressed as
wonder woman it would totally it was
just not a good look yeah the homeless
problem has gotten out of control we're
gonna get out of here but the fact that
you think a payday is a good candy bar
just [ __ ] sealed your coffin my
friends kick rapey yeah there's no
chocolate totally nuts for a payday oh
well what babe roots are oh have
chocolate on the same thing with
chocolate on top taking kick rocks too
that old bozo what's your favorite candy
bar uh snickers yeah i'm a gentleman
snickers kitkat twix okay peppermint i
like smokers as a dairy queen um
irish and an oreo dairy queen no the
blendins the blendins the blenders
blizzards blizzards yeah you've had
dairy queen recently yeah two weeks ago
in baltimore and you're pretty awesome
but uh but snickers i would do that for
that i feel i'm like a kit kat i feel
like kit kats you like a three
musketeers
yes
actually
growing up that was like kind of that to
me i thought was like the luxury
candy bar yikes no is that bad it's not
good yeah but what by the way what is
inside of three musketeers exactly
nothing styrofoam bunch of [ __ ] yeah
same [ __ ] they make yoga mats out they
claim nougat but yeah it's like a subway
sandwich
[Laughter]
subway sandwich bread i've been drooling
oh i'm sorry remember mr goodbar all the
there's a lot of candy bars that are
gone
mr goodbye are you still getting a
little in the hershey's mini pack a
little john's that's the only place
where mr goodbar was good a regular flat
mr good bar haven't you ever had one
yeah apparently i also went to a
friend's house the other day and i
crunch man growing up ooh shout out oh
that's a great call like england does
that like arrow bars like crunch a lot
of their english
english english candies all right uh uh
trader joe's has a little english candy
section arrow bars they're kind of like
this iron bars aren't too shabby i have
to put a set of eyes on them remember
whatchamacallits course caramellos
caramel
what's your girl scout cookie oh uh
samoa's okay great obviously in the
thickness great yeah great samoas were
good if someone says shortbread i just
can't oh but i do like a short break
yeah but like i don't want to be married
to it but the nut one they took away and
now they have all they have a
gluten-free one now and one the nut one
is gone what is this world cup i know
it's tragic tell you wow well i think
from that we're gonna reverse everything
and say that you're classy absolutely
not
gang the new special entitled jokes is
that on netflix right now yes so do
yourselves a favor check it out whitney
anything else you want the folks out
there to know um i hope this i don't
know if this is going to count against
me but i do not talk about trans people
in the special
i
i don't know if that's okay
uh
or cancel culture uh i'm at the website
or tour dates oh sorry
um i don't know yeah whitneycomings.org
check her out you're [ __ ] amazing
this was so much fun thank you for
having me this is i i do believe welcome
back anytime you're in new york this is
like truly the ultimate dream that you
know doing press we get to just hang out
with our friends this was [ __ ] scary
what's better than that it's crazy
what's hit by a raccoon at four in the
morning
what do you got for them guys check out
us we're all over the road new cities
shows are selling out get your [ __ ]
tickets we love you
we'll see you next week